[Music]
the spy who dumped me is in theaters
right now and at Mila Kunis catches the
eye of a certain spy a blender star Sam
heughan
oh yes he does and only easy on lines
again Aguilera was there as Sam
surprised some diehard Outlander fans
gearing up to watch his big-screen spy
give you just surprised the fans what
was that like for you they had no idea
you were coming we did and it was it was
really fun you know we've got this
competition and you know a select few
have been allowed to see it in advance
you have a real instinct for this I do
play a lot of I'm excited for a figure
to go and see it it's something I'm
really proud of I think it's really
funny and some amazing action sequences
vn hosted a Q&A with Sam before the
screening of his action comedy with Mila
Kunis and keep MacKinnon
it's an incredible movie and Miller and
Kate you know they're like two people
I've been a huge fan of to get the
opportunity to work them is it's just
incredible
Sam returns to Outlander in the fall and
a lot of fans have been clamoring for
him to play James Bond when Daniel
Craig's run is over what are your
thoughts about entering possibly
entering the double-oh-seven world the
world of double-oh-seven I think is you
know a fantastic world I grew up with
it's part of my heritage you know what I
think any actor the puts on a tuxedo is
instantly talked about for a bond I
think it's about time we had a Scottish
bond
[Music]
[Applause]